hello there obi-wan kenobi is back with
its third episode and it's time to rev
up your engines as we're going through
all the easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed as always our
breakdown is obviously gonna be filled
with spoilers so if you haven't checked
it out then check out now oh be one of
my subscribers as we're gonna be going
through the show every single week as
well as andor which will be dropping at
the end of august without the way let's
travel back to a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away and get into the
breakdown okay so last week had us
picking up on tatooine post order 66
with obi-wan kenobi now lying low
inquisitors scoured the galaxy for him
namely third sister who got a group of
flea ridden pirates to lay a finger on a
certain senator's daughter after obi-wan
rescued her from daiyu we also watched
as riva ended up taking down the grand
inquisitor since friday there's been a
lot of talk about how this breaks
continuity as the bad guy has appeared
in several things past this point but
the kind of funny podcast discussed how
the creative team have said he's alive
he's just been taking out the show so
that they can progress the plot with
other characters huge shout outs to kylo
ken under scorexa for pointing out that
the star wars novel last shot reveals
that poems have two stomachs so he could
easily have been stabbed at this point
and survived it we've had darth maul get
cut in half thundercat patch of blaster
bolts on fennec shand and there is
president there that he can outlast this
really think i'd let you take all the
credit
either way we'll get into it and we
start off with obi-wan meditating in an
attempt to reach out to qui-gon obi
wanted [ __ ] himself off from the force
and even buried his lightsaber so that
he'd be more difficult to track when it
came to the inquisitors you also get the
line by yoda
[Music]
this was said to obi-wan at the jedi
temple before he looked over the
security footage revealing anakin was
complicit in order 66. there's been a
lot of back and forth over whether yoda
knew anakin had turned at this point and
amongst the quotes we get further ones
from both anakin and qui-gon
accompanying this is shots of anakin
suiting up but whereas in films it tends
to be done in this cool way you know you
know like how they do in batman movies
here we get a feeling of pain to the
entire thing he has fake arms and legs
and even his chest panel has gigantic
spikes in it that stab into his body so
that they can be held in place every
moment of his life since mustafar has
been spent in agony and this pain has
driven him down the path of the dark
side after being assembled we cut to the
wide shot of the room which was also the
same location that we saw in rogue one
this is mustafar fortress vader aka the
home of the galaxy's biggest deadbeat
dad the design of the fortress of course
mirrors the inquisitor one and also
their ship which has two spires with a
gap in the middle vader resided here
during his time off so that he could
heal and also because it reminded him of
the place that he suffered his greatest
defeat it was a big gut punch for
obi-wan to learn that anakin was still
alive and mirroring this vader was built
thinking that padme died because of him
along with their two children this is
why he never really went searching for
luke and leia and it was only upon
enlisting boba fett that he discovered
luke was his offspring yeah he mainly
spends his time meditating dropping puns
about choking people like we got in
rogue one and also just chilling like a
villain i always kinda wish that he'd
call this the empire state building but
i can't have em all aveda is a voice
once more by james earl jones and this
creates a really intimidating
introduction and you might recognize
these shots as being ones that were
teased in the obi-wan sizzle reel
released last year according to the
leaks his performance is made up of
several people including el jones as the
voice hayden christensen for when the
mask is off and demetrius bistrevsky for
when he's in the suit last one was named
in the leaks as mentioned but whether
that's true or not i'm not 100 at this
point during this scene we get a
hologram from reverb and there's
something that they subtly do an empire
strikes back when vader spoke to the
emperor he appeared as a giant head
razier river appears like a small figure
when talking to vekt aka flee she was
shown as a much bigger figure and i
think this is put in place to cement who
holds the power over others this is also
why snoke appeared as a giant hologram
during the force awakens now what reaver
is currently after isn't clear but i had
an awesome theory dropped on my last
video by gunslinger 100. they say riva
might actually be trying to capture
obi-wan so that she can gain a private
audience with vader and then she'll be
able to enact her true plan to kill him
if she ended up becoming the grand
inquisitor then this would allow her to
meet with him privately and this would
give her an opportunity to strike him
down however there are others that are
after the c2 which is also shaped in
that sith format that's branding right
there now she may even be after this
spot as taking him down would make her
next in line to become pulp's apprentice
if she is the grand inquisitor episode 1
opened with order 66 being carried out
and the first kid we see will probably
be revealed to be here there's been a
lot of talk about how riva knew that
vader and anakin were one in the same
but i suspect that it's going to be
revealed he was the one who found her
after the jedi temple attack he was
there and would likely immediately begin
recruiting inquisitors from the off
we've had the grand inquisitor also talk
about how kenobi should be left for
darth vader and she even ended up taking
him out so i do think that it will
likely come out that this is all part of
her plan to take down the person that
destroyed her life it would make sense
that obi-wan would also be someone that
she hated too though he went to the jedi
temple with yoda he didn't really look
for any survivors and riva might end up
hating him because of this it's also
possible that her name is a play on
raven a jedi who broke away from the
order before becoming a sith much like
how she has here now we cut back to the
ship and hear leia ask how the force
works you also get this line by obi-wan
can you use the force on it or something
that's not how it works this is possibly
riffing on the similar one that hand
dropped in the force awakens from here
they traveled to mapuzo which was first
introduced in a star wars role-playing
game huge shout outs to eric varsity
rock stars were pointing out that this
was also hinted at in the trailer due to
the arabesh writing that the inquisitors
look over upon landing we see two droids
one that looks a lot like r5 but it's
difficult to tell as his motivator isn't
bust up yet the planet also has
stormtroopers on it and imperial strip
the land of its minerals throughout the
galaxy they threw lots of their efforts
into mining so that they could build
weapons like the death star and they
completely ravaged planets in order to
take what they wanted obi wan his
visions of a jedi and i believe that
this is anakin though it is difficult to
make out anakin is of course weighing
heavily on his mind as he was his
student and in failing him he caused one
of the greatest threats in the galaxy to
rise up now the show has kind of screwed
the cannon a bit as we have leia clearly
knowing obi-wan due to him rescuing her
while they're in a new hope she only
really talks about him serving her
father in the clone wars and when luke
ends up fleeing yoda seemingly reveals
to him that there is another the way
this always came across to me was that
only yoda really knew about it but they
might end up altering things in this
series suppose you could kind of write
it off as leia being 10 years old here
so she might not even remember it
because i can't really remember most of
the sh i did when i was 10. mainly
mainly because i was drunk all the time
now i've also seen people say that he
introduced himself as ben but she did
hear him get called obi-wan we of course
know that leia ended up naming his son
ben as well after kenobi which i always
found a bit weird as the pair never
actually met any new hope however this
could end up explaining that and maybe
we will get some of the plot holes
smoothed over come the end of the season
either way probably a vital
inconsistency that means absolutely
nothing and i'm just obsessing over it
because i want to waste your time and i
got you punk
see you chump
now at this point we see fortress
inquisitorius the base of the
inquisitors actually featured is the
final level in fall in order and the
spire in the sky also goes deep into the
ocean we can actually see lightsabers
that they've taken from the jedi they've
hunted in the background which is such a
nice detail arriva takes a long long
walk through the hallways in what is
some of the most epic walking that i've
ever seen bloody doesn't stop walking
now at this point she also meets the
other inquisitors and fifth brother
makes it clear that he wants the throne
now fifth brother is probably my
favorite character in the show so far
played by sun kang you'll likely
recognize him as being han from the fast
and the furious franchise i dropped a
hashtag justice for han solo joke last
week yeah
yeah and go go check out the the amazing
weight in that video now fifth brother
like the rest of the inquisitors ended
up surviving order 66 and after he was
taken in by the imperials he was trained
by the grand inquisitor and also darth
vader during training he actually ended
up having his hands sliced off a classic
thing that pretty much happens to
everyone in star wars at this point they
can't get enough now hunting surviving
jedi he joined vader on missions going
after characters like eoth koth and his
child when the grand inquisitor died
during his fight with kanan fifth
brother became one of the most important
ones and he was tasked with destroying
the rebellion he made his end attempting
to track down a sith holocron which is
when he came face to face with ezra
bridger and his new best buddy lord maul
maul ended up killing him and a lot of
the other inquisitors whilst he tried to
tempt ezra with the dark side definitely
go check out rebels if you want to know
more of his story and also the grand
inquisitors as well alongside him his
fourth sister who is a bit of an unknown
in the star wars canon she followed the
rest of the inquisitors in being
recruited from the jedi order but she's
not really appeared in the canon all
that much and is actually missing from a
lot of the articles and sites that go
over the different members because of
this we don't really know what happened
to her in the end but we do know that
she ended up losing her armor to lena
graff graf ended up wearing this and
impersonating her in order to infiltrate
fortress vader on mustafar but beyond
this we know sweet football could to
probe droids being sent out into the
galaxy a motif that was of course how he
opened the empire strikes back obi-wan
and leia reached the rendezvous point
but no one's there they flagged down a
cray carrier called freck and leia gives
the name luma luma means light and this
could have been picked by leia because
of obi-wan's speech about how the force
is like turning the light on in the dark
however loomer is also a name that has
popped up at several points with
characters like luma and lumeral i feel
like the shots in this vessel are also
meant to reflect the ones earlier from
episode 1 in which obi-wan traveled to
and from work in those scenes he was
trying to hide from the empire which he
literally has to do when they get
boarded later on they stay there from
tall the location that we visited last
week on daru after the stormtroopers
show up they say they're looking for a
jedi and hey look look at the clothes
look at the guys wearing them it's right
in front of you now obi-wan told leia to
keep quiet but he's the idiot in this
situation he passes off getting the name
wrong as seeing her mother's face when
he looks at her which was of course a
reference to padme
but man the writing in the scenes dear
me
however vivian lyra black comes through
delivering a line that's very
reminiscent of carrie fisher's
performance in return of the jedi when
she was discussing her mother so far i
think she's nailed the young version of
her character and she even asks if
obi-wan is her father this could be
reffing on anakin accusing padme and obi
wan of hooking up but my man was always
about bros before the yoast yodas now
obi-wan talk that didn't make sense now
obi-wan talks about being taken away
from his family when he was very young
and he even brings up his brother which
is something i think is new for the
canon stopped at the checkpoint by the
troopers and scanned by a probe droid
obi-wan ends up using his blaster to
take out the imperials this is covered
for him as using a lightsaber would
immediately alert vader which though
that happens he does kind of want to
avoid that fight we also get somewhat of
a wilhelm scream at some point though
not exactly when a trooper falls over
the edge
[Applause]
ambushed by more troops they're saved by
an imperial named tala who leads them to
an underground railroad-esque sanctuary
for the jedi this was discussed more in
the rebels episode path of the jedi and
it's been used a number of times to
chronicle their journey this also
provided them with new identities and
led them to jabim a planet that obi-wan
held a skirmish on during the clone wars
if you recognize tala it's likely
because she's played by indira varma who
played ellaria sand in game of thrones
they meet a loader droid called ned b
and he leads them to a safe house they
also bring up quinlan voss a jedi master
who we know from the cannon lived long
enough to see the empire fall he was
actually a renowned rule breaker which
fits into this notion of smuggling
younglings that we discover he did
although we don't know what happened
with grogu it is possible that he went
through this too and they as they say
this is the way there is still a lot of
mystery over who the jedi who saved him
was and potentially will learn it was
quinlan the entire time the piece is
broken by stormtroopers who arrive and
after realizing their compromise that
they're led away obi-wan gives the name
ben once more showing how much he has
given up on the old life much like a new
hope in the death star he senses vader
arriving on the planet which is where
everything kicks off such a cool moment
and i love how you have vader's
breathing murdering obi-wan's
guy just starts choking people in an
attempt to draw obi-wan out and as soon
as he kills the father and son you know
it's own probably reaching but obi-wan
and anakin had a father and son
relationship so him killing these firsts
could metaphorically show how he feels
about the whole dad thing he had going
on either way this choking is also
something that he did to padman revenge
of the sith before their battle like
what we have here it's sort of like
poetry they rhyme you could say and the
pair end up coming face to face obi-wan
ends up fleeing however we need bloody
fights and watching him spark it up
amongst the dark sand is absolutely
brilliant we also get a second in which
his saber is used to mirror him killing
the younglings in the prequels really
nice attention to detail by the creative
team that shows how these scenes of him
hunting the jedi reflect one another
here the lightsaber duel is far closer
to how it was in a new hope with a lot
less twirling and more of the classic
swordsmanship that the original duels
were based on great seeing them fight
once more i was actually surprised they
went head to head this early on darth
vader then drops this line
you should have killed me when you had
the chance
and we can now add it to this supercoat
you should have killed me when you had
that chance you should have killed me
when you had the chance you should have
killed me when you had the chance you
should have killed me when you had the
chance
why didn't you kill me when you had the
chance now riva ends up looking for leia
and we discover the path and tala tells
her to go on her own she comes across
the jedi crest which triggers her
because it very much adds to her feeling
of abandonment if our theory is right
which it probably is and i don't even
need to add a theory time every time
every time every time she was left to
fend her herself and she ended up
joining the inquisitors who've subjected
her to a life of torment whilst the
others got away vader ends up suspending
obi-wan in the air and he attempts to
drag him through the fire so that he
ends up suffering the same thing that
anakin did now tala gets the high ground
and she buys an escape for obi-wan and
they'll never find him no way no way can
anyone ever find him now not like they
have spaceships and stuff now they did
kind of set this up by saying that tala
wears a blaster on one side because
she's a quicker draw with it and it
gives her the opportunity to beat them
punks however riva tracks down layer
ending the episode on a big big
cliffhanger now as for my thoughts on
the series so far i'll just go into the
review i did really enjoy the first
episode but the second one was a bit meh
and my feelings were kind of up in the
air for the show however i thoroughly
enjoyed this one and it gave us what we
wanted in terms of having obi-wan
invader finally facing off love this
duel in the desert and episode 4 is
right around the corner and though i
have mixed feelings on the first two
this got me back on board and yes very
hyped now we also have some minor leaks
for the end of the video before we wrap
up there was a big plot leak posted on
reddit a while back that got the first
two episodes bang on and though it
didn't detail the others it did say some
tiny things about the rest of the series
these aren't major ones i'm not going to
spoil the ending but turn off just in
case you don't want to know you're still
here
i always give people because people kick
off if i don't give them time to to exit
the video if i just dive straight into
it right that's it now we will
apparently be getting lots of flashbacks
in the upcoming entries of a dh hayden
christensen this could potentially be
during the clone wars and both his and
obi-wan's time together or it could be
after the events of order 66. i'm
leaning more towards the latter as it
could explain riva's backstory but let
me know below exactly what you think
anyway that's the end of the leaks yeah
we got through it now i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the episode so comment
below and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now save that
to you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some emails to
watch them make sure you check out our
breakdown of stranger things which will
be linked on screen right now we went
over the entire season and talked about
the ending so if you have any questions
then definitely go head over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see in the next one take care peace